this plan focuses on four key areas
the first is
how will we increase capacity
on top of enormous levels of investment
we are doing everything in our power to
make sure that we have even more
clinicians on the front line
we now have more doctors and nurses
working in the nhs than ever before we
have a record number of students at
medical school and a record number of
students applying to train as nurses
the plan sets out what more we will be
doing including more healthcare support
workers and the recruitment and
deployment of nhs reservists
we will also be making greater use of
the independent sector which formed an
important part of our contingency plans
for covet 19 so we can help patients to
access the services they need
because of this high demand
second mr speaker
as we look at the backlog we will not
just strive to get numbers down
but also to prioritize by clinical need
and to reduce the very longest waiting
lists
assuming half of the missing demand from
the pandemic returns over the next three
years the nhs expect the waiting list to
be reducing by march 2024
addressing long waits is critical to the
recovery of elective care and we will be
actively offering longer waiting
patients greater choice about their care
to help bring these numbers down
the plan sets the ambition of
eliminating weights of longer than a
year
waits in elective care by march 2025
within this no one will wait longer than
two years by july this year and the nhs
aims to eliminate the weights of over 18
months by april 2023 and over over 65
weeks by march 2024 which equates to 99
of patients waiting less than one year
mr speaker
i've heard the concerns that some people
have rightly raised including many
honourable members about the impact of
the pandemic on cancer care
on friday
world cancer day i launched a call for
evidence that will drive a new 10-year
cancer plan for england a vision of how
we can lead the world in cancer care and
this elective plan too places a big
focus on restoring cancer services
the nhs has done sterling work to
prioritize cancer treatment throughout
the pandemic and we have consistently
seen record levels of referrals since
march 2021
but waiting times have gone up and fewer
people came forward with cancer symptoms
during the pandemic
the plan shows how we will intensify our
campaigns to encourage more people to
come forward focusing on areas where
referrals have been the slowest to
recover like lung cancer and prostate
cancer
it also sets out some stretching
ambitions for how we will recover and
improve performance for cancer care
returning the number of waiting the
number of people waiting more than 62
days from an urgent referral back to the
pre-pandemic levels by march 2023 and
ensuring that 75 of patients who have
been urgently referred by their gp for
suspected cancer are diagnosed or have
cancer ruled out within 28 days by march
2024
i'm determined that we tackle the
disparities that exist in this backlog
just as i
have been determined to tackle
disparities of any kind across this
country
analysis from the king's fund shows that
on average
you are almost twice as more likely to
experience the weight over a year if you
live in a deprived area
and as part of our recovery work we're
tasking the nhs with analyzing their
waiting list data according to factors
like age and deprivation ethnicity to
help drive detailed plans to tackle
these disparities
third mr speaker
this new chapter for the nhs provides an
opportunity to radically rethink and
redesign how services are delivered to
bust the backlog and deliver more
flexible personalized care for patients
the pandemic has shown beyond doubt the
importance of diagnostics
but although over 96 of people needing a
diagnostic test received it within six
weeks prior to the pandemic
the latest data shows that that number
has fallen to 75
our aim is that we will get back to this
get back to 95
by march 2025
and a major part of this will be
expanding the use of community
diagnostic centers which have already
had a huge impact
these are one-stop shops for checks and
scans and tests that will help people
get a quicker diagnosis and therefore
the treatment that they need much
earlier on
69 community diagnostic centers are
already up and running and the plan
shows our intention to have at least at
least 100 in the communities in local
communities and on high streets over the
next three years
we will also keep expanding the use of
surgical hubs
that will be dedicated to carrying out
planned elective surgeries they will
allow us to do more surgeries in a
single day than in in typical outpatient
settings
so we can fast track operations and make
sure patients are more likely to go home
on the same day
we have already been piloting these hubs
and we will now be rolling these out
right across the country
and then finally mr speaker we will
improve the information and support for
patients
i know the anxiety that patients feel
when they are waiting for care
especially if they feel like they don't
have the certainty about where they sit
in the queue
and i'm determined to to make sure that
as we enter this next phase we will be
open and transparent with patients
we will be launching a new online
platform called my planned care which
will go live this month offering
patients and their carers tailored
information ahead of their planned
surgery they will be able to see waiting
times for their provider so that they
can better understand their expected
weight
a third of on the day cancellations
are due to people not being clinically
ready for treatment and this new
platform will be able to link patients
to the most appropriate personalized
support ahead of their surgery
this shows the approach that we will be
taking in the years that lie ahead
putting patients at the heart of their
care and giving people giving them the
support they need to make informed
decisions
we will also put in place a payment
system that incentivizes strong
performance and delivers value for money
for the public
mr speaker
just as we came together
to fight this virus
now we must come together
on a new national mission
to fight the virus what the virus has
brought with it
it will mean waiting lists falling by
march 2024 strong action to reduce long
waiting times and stretching targets for
early diagnosis for cancer care
this vital document
shows how we will recover
but not just recover but also reform and
make sure that the nhs is there for all
of us no matter what lies ahead i
commend this statement to the house